I want to talk today a little about what
PE is at our schools and what our
parents can do to support our child's
physical education when they when they
come home so first off let me start the
easy one what PE is not physical
education is not recess physical
education class is fun there are games
there is play all those things and
recess is a wonderful time for students
to do those things
but when we are in physical education
class we're also very intentional about
what we want our students doing there
are very particular exercises we want
them to work through and the PE teacher
discerns what those exercises are and
how best to teach them so what type
exercises are we doing in a physical
education class well first off we want
three exercises that we can do on a
regular basis so things which we can
repeat from day to day and that's that's
very purposeful because when we do
things that way the kids can learn the
proper form if we only do a push-up once
every three weeks the students will
muddle through them over time but they
won't know what the actual right form is
and we're not teaching them how they can
be lifelong healthy individuals without
that regular daily reinforcement these
exercises also need to be
age-appropriate I just mentioned
push-ups push-ups are not something most
kindergarteners are capable of doing at
least not well and frankly at that age
they they don't have the upper body
strength to do it and third off we want
to choose exercise which is going to
expand the child's physical abilities so
you think grammar years.they there's a
certain lack of coordination in the
child they don't know how to use both
sides the body to and do attain one goal
they run slightly awkwardly so these are
things we're going to emphasize at that
point because they they have certain
abilities already in place we want to
take those abilities and grow them over
time last point perhaps the more
important point on what physical
education is this is an arena which we
can practice virtue we know that fatigue
is a thing which makes us want to quit
our body says no I'm done I don't want
anymore a part of being virtuous is
overcoming Evette and building a strong
having a strong mind approaching this
that we
and we can do that one more push up we
can hold the plank for 15 more seconds
we can sprint the final 10 meter stretch
our quarter-mile run and then of course
competition competition brings out many
vices especially in the young because
they want to win so they're willing to
cheat the rules because they think the
teacher isn't looking or no one will
notice and then when they're accused
they will lie about it and in a physical
education class we we take those things
very seriously these are matters of
justice right and wrong so we need to
correct these students and we need to
teach them encourage them to to play
these games fairly so they can they can
all enjoy them that much more so parents
I want to share a few ideas with what
you could do to reinforce your child's
physical education at home and the first
one perhaps won't be as popular but I
think we can all admit that we don't
exercise as much as we ought to there's
a rare individual who actually who does
I think we can answer that and say also
you know I work out as much as a person
ought to so maybe give your child a
chance to show off what they do they
come home and maybe on a Saturday
morning you ask them to show you what
did you do in PE class what kind of
exercise are you doing these days and
then join them for those exercises
don't let this become a thing where
there the coach and they're there that
barking at you you know do one more push
up nope you are joining them for this
thing and you'll get a little exercise
out of this they'll be motivated and
they'll have something to offer at the
home and I think everyone will come away
pretty well with that and play games
that they're playing in PE most most
physical education classes in play
seasonal sports so in the winter time
that's that's basketball season fall
that's volleyball and soccer season so
maybe during the course of the year on
those Saturdays maybe after school even
play those sports with them if you have
a lot of kids at home send them outside
and say you guys are playing soccer
today break them teams than you and have
at it doesn't it doesn't need to be
seasonal sports there are lots of games
which we do in PE because we have a big
group of kids some of them can be
modified for the home environment you
can do things let your like play tag
there are countless variations of that
you can do relay races not just running
back and forth across the yard but doing
crab walk or running backwards or
skipping
so first up exercising at home second
thing teach them to overcome fatigue the
one you're doing those exercises with
them before after school or you're on
the weekends
encourage them let's do one more push up
right now let's hold this plank for a
few more seconds or if if you have the
opportunity sibling rivalries can be can
be well applied here have the siblings
compete who's gonna do more push-ups
today who's gonna hold this plank plank
longer I found that competition between
friends between siblings is oftentimes
the greatest encouragement because
nobody wants their little sister to beat
them to hold that plank for that long it
invaded I mentioned earlier playing
sports which are in season but also be
aware that when you play sports at home
there's going to be argument there's
going to be accusations that someone
cheated someone lied and these need to
be treated seriously so when they come
to you asking you to be the arbiter of
in some disagreement of which you saw
nothing maybe take opportunity to not so
much be the arbitrary arbiter but talk
to them about about competition when
when you're playing in game you're there
to have fun you're there to exercise and
if someone's cheating the rules they
know when they're cheating or if someone
is accusing other person and then
argument breaks out ask them are you
guys having fun right now and I think
they will honestly admit they're not
having fun so some some some he's got to
get something's got to change encourage
them to be that fair participants that
we can actually enjoy this game that
were that we do enjoy final note just
some toys that are I think are
applicable to the home environment or
any environment allow these are basic
things footballs soccer balls volleyball
is have these at home so the kids can
make use of them whenever they want to
jump ropes or even better double dutch
ropes if you have enough personnel you
have to do those skip hops for those of
you who know what those are it's like a
ball attached to a string tied around
your ankle which you can spin around
your other foot and hop over requires
minimal coordination but somehow it's
really satisfying because you can get a
rhythm going with it an exercise ball a
hula-hoop a tug-of-war rope you can do
so many things with a tug-of-war rope
you can do one-on-one won tug-of-war
that's all you have at home and kids
love it you throw a rope in front of
children and say we're gonna do this
today they all begin screaming with
delight because tug-of-war is their
favorite thing and one two final
thoughts on indoor toys one is a
spinning board this is basically a desk
chair which the kids are encouraged to
spin around in circles on but it's just
two pieces of wood with ball bearings in
between on on ground level child sits on
it and spins themself in a circle if you
do get one of these I would encourage
you to tell your child to stare at his
feet as he's spinning because if he's
staring out he will become nauseous and
he will puke and perhaps I think I'm
saving the best for last year great
indoor toy is the giant spinning top you
can find one at Target right now I'm
sure other places seldom too but I've
had a difficult time tracking them down
this is an enormous top which a person
can climb into and then spin themselves
around in circles and it's it's a great
core workout it's a whole body workout
and it's just fun so there's a few ideas
what you guys can do at home with your
kids encourage their physical education